medical marijuana is a fascinating issue
the cause of that confusion in some
people's mind is it legitimate or is it
the camels nose under the tent were
really all legalize errs it is always
important when we're defining the proper
role of government in the life of the
individual an overwhelming majority of
citizens in this country have always
felt we should not allow the government
into our homes to monitor what books we
read to know what music we listen to to
observe how we conduct herself in the
bedroom or to decide whether we smoke
marijuana or drink alcohol when we relax
in the evening it simply is none of the
government's business and it's time for
us to stand up and say that this
statement clearly for being a marijuana
smoker is nowhere near as great today as
it would have been five or ten or twenty
years ago and certainly not 39 years ago
when we first started normal the first
few years of normal we couldn't even
talk about the fact that we enjoyed
smoking marijuana are that for some
people marijuana can be a very positive
experience we do now but back then no
way if you were perceived as being even
slightly pro-pot you were too radical to
be involved in the political process we
don't suggest you get up and get stoned
in the morning no don't get stoned and
go to work and don't drive when you're
stoned if you if you do smoke marijuana
don't drive for at least a couple of
hours it's terribly important that we
show that we're responsible smokers but
for many of us smoking a marijuana
cigarette allows us to stand back a half
a step and get a slightly better
perspective on life and some sometimes
to be a bit more thoughtful than we we
had been before so today I'm quite proud
to say I think there's absolutely
nothing wrong with the responsible use
of marijuana by adults and I would
encourage adults who drink alcohol give
it a try I think you'll find it it fits
in your life much better than alcohol
by the time people graduate high school
in this country and it's been true for a
consistent for about 20 years between 48
and fifty-two percent of those high
school graduates have smoked marijuana
by the time they graduate yet the vast
majority go on to college they graduate
they get married they have fulfilled
lives they're not pot heads they smoke
for a short time when they're young and
then they may never smoke again or is
some of the recent that is suggesting
when the kids grow up and leave the
house and they've got an empty nest and
they're semi-retired they may in fact
begin to smoke again because they have
time on their hands and it's an
enjoyable experience but I think this
whole concern about kids in marijuana is
greatly overblown of course we would
rather our kids and I same thing we're
me you don't want your kids
experimenting with any drugs when
they're young and you want to defer that
experience as long as possible but by
the time somebody's 16 or 17 or 18 years
old in this country you can pretty well
bet they have experimented with
marijuana and for most of them it
appears to have no harmful effects
normal actually defined the medical
marijuana issue in 1972 we brought the
first suit to try to force the
government to reclassify marijuana from
schedule 1 to schedule to sew a
physician could prescribe it obviously
we're still at it after all these years
but we now do have I guess 14 states
that have some version of medical
marijuana that's legal if a doctor
authorizes it many of the people that
use it are seriously under their cancer
patients undergoing chemotherapy there
ms patients there there are other
patients who suffer serious diseases in
conditions for which marijuana is
without question very helpful to them
they should of course be at the front of
the line it's hard to imagine anyone in
this country would want to deny an
effective medication the survey show
roughly eighty percent of the american
public support that now having said that
i will tell you normal thinks we ought
to keep medical users separate from
recreational users I've been smoking for
44 years I first smoked when i was a
freshman at Georgetown Law School i am
not a medical user i spoke an evening
when I relax and watch the news I pour a
glass of wine and roll a joint but it's
not a medical use at all so I don't want
to fake that I'm sick I don't want to
move to California and get a doctor's
recommendation I think that's both
dishonest but I think it's also
important that we win the political
point that there's nothing wrong with
responsible use of marijuana and I'm not
about to ask a doctor for permission to
smoke
when pop culture began to embrace
marijuana to treat it either in a
humorous fashion are in a kind of an
ordinary fashion where major players in
the in the script would smoke marijuana
and it didn't seem to cause of any great
problem you knew we were making progress
because popular culture mimics to some
extent change it's already going on in
some cases they may even lead it a
little but generally they're reflecting
changes that they picked up in the
regular culture so it's almost always a
positive sign now when individual
athletes and celebrities get identified
as marijuana smokers we get a varied
reaction because for a lot of them like
like Phelps he had tens of millions of
dollars at stake and it was clear that
he was a marijuana smoker and had been
for some time but rather than having the
courage to stand up and say look I just
won seven or eight gold medals do you
think it held me back how good do you
think I would have been if I wouldn't
have been smoking pot he all know I made
a mistake you know and he did the excuse
me but the chicken share option in this
case
I am quite encouraged by the new
administration now part of that is
because we were so disappointed under
Bill Clinton's eight years in that
everybody knew he had been a smoker he
claimed he didn't inhale but his
policies towards marijuana were no
different than his predecessors the
federal government continued to deny
there was such a thing as even the
medical use of marijuana and under
George Bush it was horrible i mean the
federal government was actually out
arresting some of the dispensaries and
occasionally even some of the patients
in the states that had legalized medical
use because it still not recognized
under federal law obama said during the
campaign he would not use federal
resources to go after and prosecute
people who were operating legally under
state medical use laws he has followed
through on that his attorney general
eric holder made a statement recently
which said that point now it doesn't
mean the states are free to do anything
they want what it said was if patients
and caregivers in the right now 13
states that have legalized medical use
if they're following the requirements of
their state law the federal government
will not harass them that's a major step
forward I think we're going to see more
positive steps from the Obama
administration not immediately my guess
is frankly the biggest change will
probably be if he's re-elected the first
year the second term is when I think
you'll see some significant push for
legal marijuana from the Obama
administration